one of the main pro-life arguments is  life begins  at conception so no matter when you do  an abortion you're taking away  somebody's life that isn't yours to take  away  great if that's what you believe but  your beliefs end  at the borders of my body if you think  it is against god  let god judge that woman if you think it  is  murder change the law but it's a legal  behavior  also if you are against abortion you  better  be out there advocating for  comprehensive sex education  free and available birth control  educating everybody about consent  let's also add to that affordable day  care affordable child care  excellent schools for anybody who wants  them you know affordable housing  like you better be out there creating a  world  in which everybody who gets pregnant is  able to care for the resulting children  because otherwise  what you really need to do is  criminalize sex